[Musique]
la vie m'a appris qu'on est tous à un
moment donné confrontés à des
difficultés à mener à relever des défis
ou des challenge dans ces moments là ça
impliquait pour moi que je me suis
sentie faible vulnérables et impuissante
quand j'ai compris que le regard que les
personnes posait sur moi pouvait être
différent du fait de mon handicap
j'ai eu qu'une seule idée en tête
c'était d'instaurer une relation de
normalité avec le reste du monde
j'avais donc adopté une stratégie qui
consistait à mettre en avant ma féminité
cette stratégie elle a fini par tourner
à l'obsession pour moi pourquoi parce
que tous les matins je passais une heure
à maquiller am camoufler et à chercher
les vêtements dans lesquels on verrait
pas mes cicatrices une telle obsession
que tous les matins j'avais des
problèmes avec mes preuves parce que
j'étais en retard en cours parce que je
me sentais pas nécessairement bien dans
mes vêtements et que j'avais chaud
puisque même en été je portais des
manches longues un jour malheureusement
pour moi j'ai plus pu me cacher on
allait avoir un cycle de ps obligatoires
pas n'importe lequel ampus natation donc
concrètement impossible de cacher quoi
que ce soit en plus il allait falloir
que je la lance à mes amis j'étais
terrifiée du coup j'ai décidé de
convoquer mes amis à une réunion de
crise et j'ai essayé de me convaincre au
plus profond de moi qu'ils
continueraient de mémé qui
continueraient à n'accepter puisque
depuis le début en soit il savait rien
et puis je me disais qu'il y en toujours
tout fait comme une personne valide
il y avait peut-être des chances pour
que him accepte encore ça c'est ce que
je voulais croire
la réalité c'est que j'étais vraiment
terrifié
du coup je leur avais donné rendez vous
dans un coin de la récréation à l'abri
des regards
et puis en allant vers eux je vous
disais tu peux le faire tes forces tu es
forces navales
je suis arrivé devant eux je me suis
tenu debout comme là devant vous
et je leur ai dit j'ai pas de jambes
j'ai deux prothèses jeu les balancer
comme ça direct vous savez un peu comme
quand vous faites une bêtise et que vous
devez l'annoncé à vos parents vous vous
parlez super vite vous fermer un peu les
yeux
et oui vous vous attendez juste avoir un
torrent de réactions à vous faire
engueuler bas c'était moi à ce moment là
donc du coup je les regarde
et puis je vois dans le regard qui sont
un peu intrigué surpris mais à part me
dire bah ok c'est pas grave on y va y a
rien eu d'autre d'un côté j'étais un
petit peu rassurés puisque je me dis pas
je crois qu'en fait ça veut dire qu'on
est toujours amis mais de l'autre
bizarrement j'étais déçu déçu pourquoi
parce que je me suis dit mais tout ça
pour ça en fait je m'étais tellement
fait une montagne de toute cette
histoire de ma condition alors qu'en
fait pour eux c'était rien c'était rien
parce que l'image que j'avais de moi
c'était pas du tout celle que je leur
envoyais et je me suis dit mais j'avais
même pas besoin de tout ce maquillage
j'avais même pas besoin d'avoir autant
de problèmes avec les profs avec mes
parents tout ça c'était du temps perdu
aujourd'hui avec le recul je suis
vraiment contente d'avoir eu à faire
cette révélation parce que la seule
chose qui a changé entre mes amis et moi
c'est qu'on est devenu plus proche
pourquoi est ce qu'on est devenu plus
proche
parce que quand je leur ai annoncé que
j'avais plus de jambes je leur ai
expliqué comment j'avais survécu à un
incendie criminel à l'âge de 5 ans dans
lequel j'avais perdu ma mère et mon
petit frère
je leur ai aussi expliqué que les
chirurgiens avaient dû m'amputer pour le
sauver d'une gangrène
je leur ai aussi dit que toujours à
l'âge de cinq ans j'avais je m'étais
réveillé d'un coma il comprenait aussi
enfin pourquoi je parlais j'amène mon
père qui avait décidé de m'abandonner à
la sortie de l'hôpital parce qu'ils
voulaient pas s'occuper d'une petite
fille handicapée et pourquoi j'étais la
seule de la classe à avoir la mention
tuteur légal et non par an puisque ma
tante et son mari m'avait recueillies à
la suite de cette révélation donc je me
suis senti beaucoup plus proche de mes
amis beaucoup plus à l'aise dans mes
relations amicales mais je veux à dire
que dans mes relations publiques et même
familiale c'est encore différent
le sport a toujours rythmé la vie
familiale et quand les amis de mes
parents où la famille venez nous visiter
il parlait de mes soeurs bas ils leur
poser des questions de sport
en même temps pour eux c'était difficile
de faire autrement parce que dans le
salon il y avait les photos les
médailles et les trophées une mes soeurs
et moi côté de ça les seules questions
auxquelles j'avais droit bel été tourné
autour de mes prothèses de ma santé et
de mon handicap
avec le recul j'ai compris qu'en fait
ces questions elles étaient plutôt
bienveillante mais à ce moment là moi la
seule chose dont j'avais envie c'était
d'être considéré comme une personne
normale
je me suis donc dit que vu que c'était
normal de faire du sport à la maison
bale j'en ferai aussi c'est là que j'ai
découvert le handisport
du coup quand j'ai commencé à faire du
sport j'ai senti un changement dans la
façon dont mes parents par les noirs
auprès de leurs amis pour la première
fois de ma vie je ressentais un brin de
fierté dans leur vin encore mieux dans
le regard des amis de mes parents ou de
ma famille
il y avait aussi un changement je me
sentais presque comme admirer et c'est
tout ce que j'avais voulu toujours voulu
être considéré comme une personne
normale
enfin il pouvait s'identifier à moi et
comme je choisissais de faire des
compétitions on parlait de mes
compétitions je gagnais je perdais ça
leur parlait j'avais des plutôt des bons
résultats dans les disciplines que je
pratiquais mai et je prenais du plaisir
sincèrement mais je vais pas vous mentir
au fond de moi j'avais toujours cette
idée de course à la normalité
ma stratégie du début mais je me suis
dit je vais continuer à faire du sport
je vais continuer à me faire plaisir et
puis on verra bien la découverte avec le
basket fauteuil à s'est fait un peu par
hasard
en fait on devait choisir un sport avec
mes amis au collège et c'était le seul
sport qu'on pouvait faire tout ensemble
en plus je sais pas si vous savez mais à
16 ans on est vraiment très copines
c'est à dire que même pour aller aux
toilettes on y va tout ensemble et donc
du coup c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé
le basket fauteuil le basket je
connaissais je pense que vous connaissez
aussi en revanche le fauteuil pas du
tout je vous la corde pour une femme qui
est censé être handicapé que je vous
dise que c'est la première fois je
découvre un fauteuil c'est bizarre mais
c'est vrai j'avais jamais été dans un
fauteuil avant faut croire que ça a été
une magnifique découverte puisque
seulement quatre ans après j'ai été la
plus jeune fille a participé aux jeux
paralympiques de rio 2016 avec l'équipe
de france de basket fauteuil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en arrivant village paralympiques
il ya un garçon de la team usa qui me
dit je t'invite à manger avec nous ce
millier donc j'accepte et puis en
arrivant à la table un de ses
coéquipiers me dit bon allez fini les
secrets maintenant dis nous c'est quoi
ton handicap gens disent je suis double
amputé et là il explose tous derrière
donc moi super impressionné je comprends
pas je leur dis bah expliquez moi une
disant fait depuis le début on était
tous persuadés est convaincu que tu
étais une athlète et que tu étais si
mince à cause d'une maladie qui
tremblaient dans cet état-là saint tin
et en fait ça m'a vraiment fait rire
dans le fond parce que je me suis dit
mais eux qui pratique du basket en
fauteuil depuis des années qu'ils
côtoient des personnes en situation de
handicap depuis des années ils arrivent
à se tromper sur mon handicap
et c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
m'avait interpellé deux semaines après
je rejoins mon club des hornets au
cannet et puis à la fin d'un match le
président vient me voir et me dit faut
que je te dise un truc tu vas être mort
de m donc je dis pas je t'écoute et
hindi donc les supporters qui m'a dit tu
félicitera grèce pour ses tatouages sur
son bras droit parce qu'ils sont
vraiment bien réussi
et là je me suis dit oui effectivement
c'est drôle mais je vais laisser croire
que c'est des tatouages parce que je
pense qu'il va être mal à l'aise si je
dis que c'est des cicatrices de brûlures
en l'espace de deux semaines j'avais
vécu deux situations plutôt différente
mais aussi très similaire à la fois
c'est à dire que d'une personne
handicapée à - personnes handicapées il
avait réussi à se tromper sur mon
handicap et d'une personne valide à -
personnes handicapées il avait aussi
réussi à tromper sur le handicap est en
fait je me suis rendu compte que bas il
y avait plusieurs visions du handicap
est le plus souvent elle est formaté et
associés au fauteuil pourquoi je dis ça
je dis ça parce qu'en fait je compte
même plus le nombre de fois où je me
gare sur une place handicapée et qu'en
descendant donc en marchant on me lance
des regards noirs au conflit mais
mademoiselle vous savez que c'est une
place handicapée oui je sais ou encore
quand je vais faire les soldes dès qu'il
ya la queue à la caisse et que je
demande excusez moi vous aurez pas une
caisse prioritaire et qu on me répond
vous marchez je pense pas que vous en
ayez besoin
oui je sais
et en fait je pense que ma vision du
handicap à moi elle est sans doute même
différente de la vôtre parce que moi ma
vision du handicap c'est juste des
personnes comme moi à qui il manque
quelques morceaux et qui découvrent
vivent quand même leur vie ou parce que
la faute à pas de chance se retrouvaient
sur des roulettes et en fauteuil roulant
mais vivent quand même leur vie de
manière autonome et indépendante
ma vision du handicap elle est aussi
différente de celle qui associe bas le
handicap au téléthon j'avais une amie la
première fois qui est qu'elle m'a
rencontrée elle m'a dit mais c'est
génial en fait tu fais le téléthon toi
aussi
pas du tout et puis quand je lui ai
expliqué ma condition elle m'a dit mais
en fait je crois une chose c'est que
c'est vraiment il ya vraiment un truc
d'injuste entre toi et moi et je lui ai
dit mais qu'est ce qu'il ya elle me dit
toi tu peux changer ta taille de
prothèses quand tu veux et surtout t'as
pas besoin de tes pieds les gens quand
j'ai compris ça qu'il y avait plusieurs
différends du handi différentes visions
du handicap
j'ai compris qu'en fait les regards que
je pouvais recevoir dans la rue ou dans
n'importe quel environnement jeu
pourrait évoluer
ils n'étaient pas forcément négatif il
m'aura fallu des années pour comprendre
ça mais ça fait seulement quelques temps
que je me sens libre dans mon handicap
ça fait seulement quelques temps que
j'ai accepté de me laisser regarder que
j'ai accepté le regard des autres de
toutes les interventions que chez amené
à faire grâce au basket fauteuil je me
suis rendu compte qu'avec les enfants
c'est plus facile parce que c'est plus
rapide
il faut en général même pas cinq minutes
avant de casser toutes les croyances et
les a priori qui peuvent avoir sur les
personnes handicapées
donc ça va du petit garçon qui me dit
qu'en fait être handicapé c'est génial
parce qu'il s'est éclatée sur mon
fauteuil l'isthme de sport à la petite
fille qui me dit qu'en fait c'est pas si
terrible que ça puisque je marche et que
je vis une vie plutôt ordinaire comme sa
star préférée ou son athlète préféré est
en fait il y en a une qui m'a vraiment
marqué je vais rencontrer cet été aux
championnats d'europe et c'était une
petite espagnole
donc elle me voit m'entraîner sans mes
prothèses sur mon fauteuil de sport et
elle veut voir marché à la fin de
l'entraînement avec mes prothèses et
elle vient me voir et m 10
je pense que tu as vraiment un bon karma
parce que tu es aussi forte santé jambes
qu'avec tes jambes et là je suis resté
vraiment choqué parce qu'elle était
toute petite
donc je demande à sa maîtresse mais là
quel âge m 10 6 ans et sa maîtresse
aussi elle était bouche bée je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait vraiment un
truc fascinant avec la façon dont les
enfants perçoivent la différence et voit
le handicap
je me suis vraiment demandé mais qu'est
ce qui nous est arrivé en grandissant et
je pense sincèrement que nous en tant
que jeune adulte et en tant qu'adulte
on a énormément à apprendre d'eux parce
que moi à chacune de ses interventions
j'étais censé leur enseigner quelque
chose mais finalement je me rends compte
que j'ai beaucoup plus appris d'eux que
de moi alors aujourd'hui j'ai qu'une
seule question à vous poser
si demain vous reveniez des enfants
comment est-ce que vous verriez le
handicap
merci
[Applaudissements]